in the last video we started to
construct a spacetime diagram from my
frame of reference and I'm just drifting
through space and I'm assuming that I'm
an inertial frame of reference which
means I'm moving at a constant velocity
versus relative to all other frames of
reference and we set up a situation
where I emitted a photon right at time
zero so after one second it would have
moved three times ten to the eighth
meters after two seconds it would have
moved six times ten to the eighth meters
and then we had we added a little bit of
flavor to our little scenario where
right at time zero a friend passes me up
in her spaceship and she's traveling and
relative to me in the positive
x-direction at half the speed of light
and so we plotted her path right at time
zero her spaceship is right there I
could draw the spaceship it's at the
origin then after one after one second
she would have traveled she would have
traveled one and a half times ten to the
eighth meters after two seconds she
would have traveled three times 10 to
the eighth meters so this blue line in
the last video was her path but now I
want to make it even more interesting
let's assume that we have actually a
whole train of spaceships all traveling
in the positive x-direction at the same
velocity as her spaceship so this is her
spaceship right over here at time equal
zero she is exactly where I am but let's
say that 3 times 10 to the 8th meters in
front of her there's another spaceship
traveling traveling at exactly one and a
half times 10 to the 8th meters per
second so there's traveling at the same
relative velocity to me but if you think
about it from each of their point of
view they would seem to be stationary
because the distance between them in
this x-direction is going to stay the
same so this person at time zero is
going to be 3 times 10 to the 8th meters
in the positive x-direction from me now
if I were to wait two seconds they are
going to be so if I were to wait two
seconds they are going to be they are
going to be 6 times 10 to the 8th meters
away from me because they're going half
the speed of light and so I could draw
their path and I'm going to do it in a
slightly more muted thinner color so
that we what I'm essentially going to be
doing here is I'm setting up
lines for for my friends alternate frame
of reference I'm going to put that on
top of my frame of reference and to be
clear I'm not assuming special
relativity I'm assuming a Newtonian
world classical mechanics just to get
familiar with these ideas and to see
where the Newtonian world is going to
break down but let's say that's not the
only ship let's say there was another
ship that at time equals zero is 6 times
10 to the 8th meters away from me in the
positive x-direction well where are they
going to be where are they going to be
after after two seconds
well after we'll see after one second
they're going to be one and a half times
10 to the 8th meters further then after
2 seconds they're going to be they're
going to be they're going to be 3 times
10 to the 8th meters further and then
after 3 seconds
after 3 seconds so they're going to be 1
1 and 1/2 times 10 to the 8th meters
further than that
so their path is going to look like so
let me draw this so I'm really just
doing these to show what stationary
objects in my friends frame of reference
how they actually look to me and these
should be parallel lines these should be
parallel lines so that's a pretty good
attempt and so all and let me and so let
me actually just set up that alternate
frame of reference so this is going to
be not only my x axis I'm also going to
call this my X prime axis and I'll do in
a second of thinking about how we can
read this so I can color this in with
the blue color actually let me do it in
that light blue color that we're going
to be using for my friends frame of
reference so this is also this is also
going to be our X prime axis overlaid
and this one let me call this the T
prime axis so my friend's frame of
reference I'm going to call that the
prime frame of reference or if I called
if I called my frame of reference the S
frame of reference I can call my friends
Fame frame of reference the s prime the
S prime frame of reference and so let me
draw a horizontal lines to show the
passage of each second so that's one
second
two seconds three seconds so on and so
forth so let's make sure we're
comfortable with reading what's going on
here so a point let's say this point on
our diagram you see this point on our
diagram from my frame of reference in
the S frame of reference this is the
point time is or space or my distance my
distance from the origin in the positive
x-direction is going to be I just drop a
I just go parallel to my vertical axis
so I'm just going to do that and I get
four point five times ten to the eighth
meters so four point five times ten to
the eighth meters and what is our so I
can write the unit's there if I want and
our time is at one second one second so
this is our coordinates from this is the
coordinates from my frame of reference
from the s frame of reference I guess s
for Sal and so what would be the frame
what would be those same coordinates
from my friend's frame of reference
let's say her name is Sally or s prime
well from her frame of reference our
time is still one second we see the
horizontal line there we're just going
parallel to our horizontal axis for our
x axis so the time is still one second
but her the distance that the or the x
coordinate is three times ten to the
eighth meters three times ten to the
eighth meters and I really want you to
sit and think about this and even take
out a ruler and draw this on your own
paper and and feel good about this now
why does this make sense well this you
could view this point as where that
second spaceship was after a second and
from Sally's point of view from the S
prime frame of reference at time equals
zero that person that ship was three
times 10 to the eighth meters in front
of her and after a second that spaceship
is still three times 10 to the eighth
meters in front of her after two seconds
is still three times 10 to the eighth
meters in front of her and so from her
point of view and her frame of reference
it is stationary so the way to read this
for any point if you want my frame of
reference you the tie
is easy you just go horizontally to
either one so on her axis we have
essentially just taken the coordinate
axis and and sheared it and skewed it
this is still one second this is two
seconds this is three seconds but it
turned all of these kind of a grid of
squares if I were to draw a grid for my
coordinates into a bunch of into a bunch
of of parallelograms which we see right
over here and so for any given point in
remember this we're thinking of
Newtonian space space and time to read
it we go horizontally for time in either
in either case but for me you would go
draw it straight down because my time
axis is vertical you go straight down
and you read where it intersects the
x-axis to say figure out what our
position but for in her frame of
reference we move parallel to her T axis
or her T prime axis I should say to get
what her x I guess we could say what her
X prime coordinates are going to be so
this is X prime T Prime this is X and
this is T now what's clear at any given
point at any given point T is going to
be equal to T Prime or we could say T
prime is equal to T either way but
what's the relationship between X Prime
and X well let's think about that for a
second so when X is 4.5 times 10 to the
8th meters X prime is 3 times 10 to the
8th meters and so it looks like it looks
like X prime is going to be equal to X
minus well what's it going to be - it's
going to be minus 1.5 times 10 to the
8th meters but that that difference is
going to grow as time goes on meters per
second times times the amount of time
that has passed by and you should see
that because this is after one second
after one second the difference is 1.5
times 10 to the 8th meters after 2
seconds after suit 2 seconds so let's
look at this point right over here in my
frame of reference that person is
sitting at 6 - 6 times 10 to the
eight meters in the positive x direction
but in Sally's frame of reference in the
s prime frame of reference they're still
at three times ten to the eighth meters
in the positive x-direction so we would
multiply two seconds times one point
five times ten to the eighth so we have
three times ten to the eighth meters we
so we take six times 10 to the eighth
which would be that we subtract out
three times ten to the eighth and we get
the coordinates in s prime so this might
get a little bit confusing and the key
here is really try to draw this yourself
and really try to plot points and think
about how they are different coordinates
in the different frames of reference or
different time space coordinates in the
different frames of reference